Comment faire pour écrire un nombre ? Je vous
assure la question est pas si idiote que ça.
Si c’est un nombre entier, ça va. On l’écrit
comme une suite de chiffres. Mais si c’est un
nombre réel, du genre Pi ? Généralement ce
qu’on fait pour un nombre réel quelconque,
c’est d’utiliser l’écriture décimale :
on écrit les chiffres après la virgule.
[PI Pour Pi vous en connaissez sans
doute quelques-un 3.1415926 etc.
Il y a des moyens mnémotechniques pour
retenir les décimales avec des phrases.]
Le problème c’est que pour Pi, il y a un nombre
infini de décimales. Et donc on est obligés de
s’arrêter au bout d’un moment, et on n’écrit
finalement qu’une approximation du nombre Pi. Et
donc dire qu’on peut écire un nombre en écrivant
la suite de ses décimales, c’est pas si simple.
Bon il y a certains cas où ça ne pose
pas de problèmes. D’abord évidemment,
quand il n’y a qu’un nombre fini de décimales,
par exemple pour les nombres comme 3.742. Là
c’est bon. On appelle ça d’ailleurs les
nombres décimaux. Autre cas assez facile,
c’est quand les décimales
finissent par se répéter.
[RATIONNELS Par exemple 1/3, c’est 0.3333333
etc. Jusque’à l’infini… Mais c’est pas toujours
un seul chiffre qui se répète, la répétition
peut aussi concerner plusieurs décimales.
Par exemple 152/333 c’est 0.456456456456
etc… Et parfois la période de répétition
est suffisamment longue pour qu’on ne
s’en rende pas vraiment compte au début.
Par le nombre 3/17, qu’a l’air
innocent en apparence : c’est
0.17 64 70 58 82 35 29 41_17 64 70 58…ça y est ça
se répète. Et le motif périodique qu’on
obtient est constitué de 16 chiffres.]
Et en fait ce phénomène de répétition se
produit avec n’importe quel nombre rationnel,
c’est à dire n’importe quel nombre
qui s’écrit comme une fraction. Le
développement décimal d’un nombre rationnel
finit toujours par être périodique. Il ne
commence pas forcément périodique,
mais il finit toujours pas y arriver.
[Par exemple 5014/41625 c’est 0.120456456456456…
Pour écrire de façon compacte ces nombres réels
dont le développement décimal fini par se répéter,
on utilise une notation avec une barre au-dessus,
qui veut dire : on répète ce groupe à l’infini.]
Ca a l’air très bien, mais il y a
quand même une petite subtilité.
Et ça concerne les nombres comme 0.999999999 etc.
[0.9999 Ce nombre, on a l’impression qu’il est
très proche de 1, mais que ça n’est
pas exactement 1. Et pourtant si,
le nombre 0.9999999 jusqu’à l’infini est
*exactement* et rigoureusement le nombre 1.
Une façon plus correcte de le dire, c’est
que la notation décimale 0.999999 etc,
est une notation décimale
qui désigne le nombre 1.]
Généralement quand je dis ça, la
moitié des gens trouvent ça évident,
et l’autre moitié trouve ça complètement
absurde. Mais pourtant c’est vrai.
[DEMOS Il y a plein de démonstrations plus ou
moins rigoureuses, comme de multiplier 1/3 par 3.
Moi celle que j’aime bien c’est la suivante
: appelons x ce nombre : 0.99999 etc Si on
le multiplie par 10, on obtient le
nombre 9.9999999 etc qui n’est autre
que 9 au quel on ajoute x lui-même. Et
x vérifie donc l’égalité 10x = 9 + x,
et si vous résolvez l’équation, il
n’y a qu’une solution, c’est x=1.]
Je vous rassure, on peut donner un cadre encore
plus formel à tout cela, et le phénomène existe
pour tous les nombres dont l’écriture décimale
se termine par une suite infinie de 9. Et en
fait pour n’importe quel nombre décimal, par
exemple 3.742, on peut utiliser la notation
alternative qui est 3.74199999999. Ces deux
notations décimales désignent le même nombre.
On l’a dit : quand un nombre est
rationnel, les décimales se répètent,
donc on s’ennuie assez vite. Par contre
quand c’est un nombre irrationnel,
la suite des décimales semble assez
aléatoire, souvenez-vous pour Pi.
Ce qui est amusant avec Pi, c’est que si vous
prenez n’importe quelle séquence de chiffres,
disons «123666», vous pouvez
chercher si elle apparait dans pi.
[UNIVERS Et la réponse est oui, elle apparait à la
1 371 586e position. Même principe si je prends,
allez, 08081958 la date de naissance de Francis
Lalanne, elle apparait à la position 104 250 003.]
Et en fait on pense que ça marche avec
n’importe quoi. Toute séquence finie
de chiffres se trouverait quelque
part dans les décimales de pi. Il
suffit juste de chercher assez loin. On dit
parfois que Pi serait un nombre Univers.
C’est assez perturbant comme propriété, le
fait d’être un nombre Univers. A part votre
date de naissance, et votre code de carte
bleue : ça veut dire que vous prenez la 5e
symphonie de Beethoven en mp3, c’est un fichier
informatique, vous mettez ça sous une forme
binaire : une grande suite de 0 et de 1. Eh
bien cette suite se trouve quelque part dans Pi.
Ca marche aussi avec une photo de
vous en format JPG. Ou un film de
vous. Et même avec un film fictif qui
serait genre : le seigneur des anneaux
avec vous dans le rôle de Gandalf. Ce film
hypothétique existe quelque part dans pi.
Et en fait, pour en revenir aux maths, c’est même
encore pire que ça : dans les décimales de pi,
chaque séquence finie de chiffres va
apparaitre un nombre infini de fois,
et avec une fréquence qui
ne dépend que de sa taille.
[Par exemple ma séquence 123666
qui est faite de 6 chiffres. Si
on regarde 200 millions de décimale
de pi, elle apparait 217 fois dans
ces 200 millions. Donc en moyenne
à peu près une fois sur un million.
Et en fait n’importe quelle autre séquence de
6 chiffres apparaitra aussi une
fois sur un million en moyenne.
Pour les dates de naissance, c’est 8 chiffres,
donc ce sera une fois sur
100 millions en moyenne.]
Alors je vous raconte tout
ça avec l’exemple de Pi,
mais ça marche avec plein d’autres nombres
réels. Et d’ailleurs les nombres réels
qui ont cette propriété, on les appelle des
nombres «normaux». Alors pourquoi normaux ?
Eh bien parce que le mathématicien
Emile Borel a démontré qu’il y avait
infiniment plus de nombres normaux
que de nombres qui ne le sont pas.
Les mathématiciens disent que «presque
tout» les nombres réels sont normaux.
Et dans ce contexte là, quand les
mathématiciens disent «presque»,
ça veut pas dire «en gros», ça veut dire
un truc très précis, qui est que l’ensemble
des nombres pour lesquels ça ne marche pas est
de mesure nulle. Ce qu’on peut grossièrement
traduire en disant qu’il y en a infiniment
moins que nombres pour lesquels ça marche.
Et donc on pense que Pi est un nombre normal,
chaque fois qu’on cherche ça semble fonctionner
parfaitement. Mais on ne sait pas le démontrer. En
fait on pense que c’est le cas aussi de racine(2),
du nombre e, etc. Mais on ne sait pas
non plus le démontrer. En fait il n’y
a qu’une poignée de nombres réels dont on
sache avec certitude qu’ils sont normaux.
C’est vraiment bizarre comme situation. D’un
côté on sait que presque tous les nombres
réels sont normaux, qu’il y a infiniment plus
de nombres normaux que de nombres anormaux,
et pour autant on n’en connait
que quelques uns avec certitude.
Bien, maintenant qu’on a décortiqué l’écriture
décimale, on va essayer autre chose. Revenons
à notre nombre Pi, 3.1415926…machin. Tout
ça Si on veut en faire une approximation,
à part couper le nombre de décimales,
est-ce qu’on peut faire mieux ?
[FRACTION Alors regardons, déjà on pourrait
dire que pi est presque égal 3. Si on fait ça,
on néglige la partie décimale qui est
0.1415 etc. Mais je voudrais garder un
peu de cette partie décimale,
et voici ce que je vais faire.
Si j’inverse 0.1415…, j’obtiens
7.0625… Donc je peux très bien
écrire que pi c’est 3 + 1/7.0625…
C’est bon vous me suivez jusque là ?
Et si je veux faire une approximation,
je peux jeter la partie décimale du
dénominateur. Et j’obtiens que pi
c’est presque 3 + 1/7. Et c’est vrai,
3+1/7 c’est 3.1428 etc donc c’est vraiment
pas mal comme approximation de pi.
Maintenant la petite partie décimale
que j’ai jeté, je peux refaire la même
chose que tout à l’heure. Ce 0.0625… je
peux l’inverser et l’écrire 1/15.99659.
Là ce serait assez tentant d’arrondir
15 à 16, mais je ne vais pas le faire,
et je vais conserver la même idée
: je vais jeter la partie décimale.
On a donc que pi c’est 3 + 1 / 7
+ 1/15. Et on peut recommencer ce
petit jeu autant de fois qu’on veut,
en inversant les parties décimales et
en arrondissant. On obtient alors une
espèce d’immense fraction étagée. On
appelle ça une fraction continue. Et on peut
faire ça pour n’importe quel nombre réel.]
[FRACTION 2 : Et en fait vous voyez
que tout ce qui compte pour décrire
complètement une fraction continue, ce sont
les nombres entiers qu’on a là. Donc on peut
par convention simplifier la notation,
et ne donner que la suite des entiers.
Avec cette notation, on a pi
= [3;7;15;1;292;1..etc]. Et
on peut faire le parallèle avec la
notation décimale. Ici c’est pareil,
on donne une suite de nombres,
et on s’arrête quand on veut,
et plus on en donne, plus on décrit avec
précision le nombre réel dont on parle.]
Un des interêts de cette notation, c’est que
ça fournit des approximations assez facilement.
[APPROXIMATIONS Imaginez que je m’arrête
dès le début. Si je ne garde que les deux
premiers termes pour Pi, Donc 3 + 1/7
et que je réduis au même dénominateur,
ça fait 22/7, qui est l’approximation
rationnelle de pi la plus simple qu’on ait.
Mais je veux pousser plus loin, je prends 3
+ 1/(7+1/15), je réduis au même dénominateur,
et j’obtiens 333/106, qui vaut 3.141509,
très proche de pi. Et plus je choisis
d’aller loin dans le développement, plus
j’obtiens des approximations précises.]
Et il y a même un théorème, dû à Lagrange, qui
dit que ces approximations rationnelles sont
les meilleures possibles. Et par «meilleur»,
il faut entendre que si on veut plus précis,
on est obligé de faire intervenir
des dénominateur plus grands.
Un corollaire de ça, c’est que c’est
intéressant de tronquer juste avant un
gros nombre dans le développement, par
exemple 292 dans pi. Parce qu’un gros
nombre signifie qu’on va se prendre
un dénominateur beaucoup plus gros,
pour une amélioration dans la
précision pas énorme. Vous voyez ici.
Et plus les nombres du développement sont petits,
plus ça signifie que le nombre réel est en quelque
sorte difficile à approximer par des rationnels.
[NOMBRE D’OR Et d’ailleurs si
j’écris le pire cas possible,
le nombre 1;1;1;1;1;1 qu’est-ce que j’obtiens ?
Eh bien j’obtiens 1.61803 etc qui est le
nombre d’or. Donc le nombre d’or est en un
sens le nombre réel le plus difficile à approximer
avec des nombres rationnels. Diabolique, non ?]
Un des avantages de cette notation,
c’est qu’elle est unique. Contrairement au
développement décimal où il y a parfois cette
petite blague avec 99999, ici pas de problème.
Il n’y a qu’une seule façon de l’écrire.
Il n’y a qu’une seule façon si on s’astreint
à ce qu’on a fait là. C’est à dire à mettre
uniquement des 1 sur les numérateurs des
fractions. Si on s’autorise n’importe quoi,
alors il y a une infinité de façon
de décompositions de ce genre.
[GENERALISATION D’ailleurs rien que pour le
nombre pi il en existe quelques unes d’assez
fascinantes, parce qu’elles ont des régularités
surprenantes. Je vous laisse les découvrir.]
Pour finir sur le thème des fractions continues,
je vais vous exposer un problème
ouvert vraiment intriguant.
[KHINTCHINE Prenez un nombre réel,
n’importe lequel, et écrivez le
en fraction continue. Vous obtenez donc
une suite de nombres a0, a1, a2, a3 etc.
Et faites la moyenne géométrique des N premiers
nombres. La moyenne géométrique c’est pas comme
la moyenne usuelle : on fait le produit
et on prend la racine Nième du résultat.
Donc si on fait ça, et qu’on le fait
en prenant N de plus en plus grand,
avec presque n’importe quel nombre réel ça va
tendre vers une valeur qui est environ 2.685, et
qu’on appelle la constante de Khintchine. Pourquoi
cette valeur là en particulier ? Mystère !]
Et ça marche pour «presque» tous les nombres
réels. A nouveau, ça veut dire en gros qu’il y a
infiniment plus de nombre pour lesquels ça marche,
que de nombres pour lesquels ça ne marche pas.
Pour le coup on connait quelques nombres pour
lesquels ça ne marche pas. Le nombre d’or par
exemple, évidemment on a dit que c’était que
des 1, ou bien le nombre racine de 2 ou encore
e. Numériquement, ça semble fonctionner
pour pi, mais on ne sait pas le démontrer.
Cette constante de Khintchine, je trouve
ça vraiment super bizarre. J’ai du mal à
comprendre comment ça peut être vrai,
que pour presque tous les nombres on
tombe forcément là-dessus. Et pourtant Khintchine
l’a démontré. Par contre il reste des problèmes
ouverts quant à la nature de cette constante,
on ne sait même pas si elle rationnelle ou pas.
Bon puisque l’épisode est consacré aux différentes
manières qu’on a de décrire les nombres réels,
je voudrais terminer par ce qui ressemble à
un petit paradoxe, et qui peut vous amuser si
vous êtes familiers avec les notions d’infinis
dont je parlais dans mon épisode sur le sujet.
Le nombre pi, on a vu qu’il a une suite infinie
de décimales qui ne se répètent pas, et donc on
ne peux pas l’écrire en entier. Pour autant,
on peut quand même en parler, puisqu’on sait
en donner une définition, avec de la géométrie ou
des fonctions trigonométriques, ou des intégrales.
Donc on est capable de parler
sans ambiguïté du nombre pi,
même si on ne sait pas l’écrire, et ce grâce
à une suite de symboles mathématiques définis.
Et d’un point de vue formel, c’est toujours
comme ça. Si on se fixe un systèmes d’axiomes,
on peut toujours ramener la définition d’un nombre
à une suite finie de symboles fixés d’avance.
Et là ce qui est bizarre, c’est
que les suites finies de symboles,
il y en a une infinité, mais ce qu’on
appelle une infinité dénombrable.
C’est à dire qu’on pourrait les numéroter
0,1,2,3, en les classant par taille et par
ordre alphabétique. Il y en a en quelque
sorte «autant» que de nombres entiers.
Mais des nombres réels, il y en a infiniment
plus que de nombres entiers. Je vous renvoie
à ma vidéo sur l’infini si ça vous
trouble. Et donc les nombres réels
«qu’on peut décrire» sont infiniment moins
nombreux que les nombres réels en général.
Une fois qu’on se fixe un système d’axiomes et les
symboles qui vont avec, la majorité des nombres
réels sont inaccessibles, au sens qu’on ne peut
même pas les définir. C’est assez bizarre, non ?
Alors petite remarque pour finir
de vous donner mal à la tête,
Il faut bien préciser qu’on parle de description
au sein d’un système formel qu’on s’est fixé. On
peut toujours ruser en sortant du système. On
peut faire le parallèle avec ce qu’il se passe
pour le théorème de Gödel, et là aussi
je vous renvoie à ma vidéo sur le sujet.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui. Je vous prépare
un plus gros morceau pour dans quelques semaines,
passez une belle fin d’été si c’est toujours
l’été. Abonnez à vous pour ne rien rater des
prochaines sorties, on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle vidéo. A bientôt.